(light music)
- Your second trimester is a terrific time
to start considering
which prenatal classes
you would like to take.
Preparing for the birth of your baby
will help you feel more confident,
both labor and delivery
and caring for your baby subsequently.
The classes we will discuss today include,
hospital tours, childbirth
education and preparation,
infant care, and breast feeding.
Let's start with the hospital tour.
We recommend that you tour the location
where you plan to have your baby.
See labor rooms makes it easier
what it will be like to give birth.
You will also feel more empowered to know
where to go when the time comes.
Ask questions such as,
where can we leave the car
when we arrive in labor?
Where do we check in, and does the baby
stay in the room with me the entire time?
It's important to feel
prepared for going into labor.
Childbirth education
and preparation classes
cover topics like, how
to know when you should
go to the hospital for your delivery.
These classes include strategies such
as breathing exercises and positioning
to help you cope with pain during early
and active labor.
It's helpful to ask questions such as,
what can I do during early labor
to help me copy with contractions, and,
how can my partner best
support me through the process?
Infant care classes
may include information
about newborn care, infant CPR
and information about newborn
immunization recommendations.
You will learn about
recommended medications
given to your baby during
the first few hours of life,
and what kind of routine testing is done.
Ask questions such as,
how can I best prepare
for my baby's arrival at home?
What information should
I bring to the hospital?
What are key signs or
symptoms to watch for
in my baby after birth?
If you plan to breast feed,
preparation is important for success.
At a breast feeding
class you can learn about
strategies for successful breast feeding.
Get information about breast pumping
when you need to be away from your baby,
and connect with support
groups for after delivery.
Questions to ask include,
who can provide support
to me after delivery for
sustaining breast feeding?
What kind of breast pump
is right for my situation?
There are many classes available to cover
these topics and more.
Talk with your provider
to find out what options
are available near you.
(light music)